we're running out of time can i ask one
more question because you mentioned the
monuments
we don't have time to really explain it
i just want to yes or no
how far does it go i think everybody's
in agreement now we should get rid of
all the
confederate ones now people some people
are talking about well
washington and jefferson were slave
holders to those
do those monuments go as well first off
big fan of george washington all right
i've studied him my whole life
he you would think that lincoln would be
my favorite president
i love lincoln i love george washington
he showed us the way the way of
moderation he
freed his slaves look jefferson had kids
with slaves
so you know he loved black people but
so i don't know what i think bill but
i'm just saying
let him have to tear down their
monuments
they were flawed men of the
enlightenment they
knew what they were doing was
hypocritical but they wrote and built
into this
brilliant loving system i love the
american system
because they knew that their progeny
would try to defornicate
their own errors and move forward as i
said
as as men of thinking the problem is you
hit a stone wall of donald trump
where thinking goes out the window
tribalism and racism
rears its ugly head back to the george
wallace era
and now the american experiment takes
two steps back
backwards and then you have these murder
these shootings by cops
and now it's time for that next step
forward but you don't have to tear down
confederates all traders monuments go
all base names out out of the capital
rotunda
they betrayed this nation everybody else
founders of the country here's a
distinction i would make
that the statues that were put up in
order to and especially
later in time to defend specifically
uh the the ideals of white supremacy
should either go
or have something attached to them
explaining why and when they were put up
there
but that you can't go through a
country's history
all its stature all its human beings
apply the standards of 2020
to everybody in the 18th century and
then tear down
everything that represents the past we
are the past we need to understand it
and and put up more statues okay rather
than tearing them down
guys and if you are going to take them
down do it through the democratic
process
you